quand on parle de cyclones terme
français en fait on parle de plusieurs
choses la définition d'un cyclone qu'est
ce que c'est c'est simple c'est une
perturbation météorologique qu'un centre
et des vents qui tournent autour
toujours dans le même sens sens inverse
des aiguilles d'une montre
mais ça ne dit pas si les vents sont
forts ou pas donc cyclone ça veut pas
dire forcément vents très forts dans la
famille si claude il ya des dépressions
tropicales dépression tropicale c'est
quand effectivement il ya un centre les
vents mais les vents qui sont en gros
inférieur à 60 kilomètres/heure donc
c'est le premier stade du cyclone mais
c'est une dépression tropicale
deuxième stade du cyclone si le
phénomène se renforce les vents sont en
gros entre 60 et 120 kilomètres heure
on appelle ça une tempête tropicale et
là on commence à le donner un nom à
cette tempête alors qu'avant les
dépressions uniquement un numéro on va
dire dépression tropicale numéro quatre
numéros cinq tempêtes tropicales on lui
donne un nom comprendre une liste qui
revient tous les 6 ans si le phénomène
se renforce encore ça devient un ouragan
et c'est là souvent qu'on fait là qui
peut la confusion entre ouragans et
cyclones ouragans c'est le cyclone qui a
beaucoup de vents puissants en général
les vents sont supérieurs à 120 km/heure
et bien sûr peuvent dépasser les 200
voire 250 km donc c'est ce terme ou à
gand souvent qu'on confond avec le terme
cyclone pourquoi parce que dans notre
bassin atlantique et caribéens
on dépend d'une appellation anglo saxon
puisque le centre responsables désignés
par l'organisation mondiale météo c'est
le centre américain que vous connaissez
le national hurricane center qui à miami
et donc on a francisé le terme tropicale
cyclon en cyclone